Last one.
>> So, the last one we have
our expectation again,
which I like, and
now we are going to do minimax.
What you said, before we
started going through the quiz,
is that you are kind of treating
this as a joint action space.
It's sort of you taking an action and
then your opponent taking an action and
so on and so forth.
Really, I don't know what
I would call this, but
it looks a lot like just regular old
game search when you have zero sum game.
>> Yeah, zero sum game,
that's exactly what I would call it.
And we're going to talk a lot more
about variations of algorithms
that act like this that deal with
the case when there's multiple agents.
But this was sort of a nice
setting to bring it up because
the basic result says that if
we've got a generalized MDP.
We've got this operator and
this operator defined in such
a way that it's a non-expansion.
And it turns out all these things,
mini-max, this rank-weighted idea,
max, the linear combination,
expectation, min.
All these things are all non-expansion.
So all these things value iteration
will do something reasonable.
It'll actually come out with
a fixed point in the limit.
>> So actually min, max,
all of these things and
ord, row of ord,
they're all convex sums.
So does this mean that all convex
combinations are non-expansive?
>> So that's a great question.
They are all convex combinations,
that's true.
It is not the case that arbitrary convex
combinations result in non-expansions.
In particular,
if the weights of the convex combination
depend on the values, the actual
magnitude of the values in some way,
then we need not get anything
that is a non-expansion.
>> Okay.
So, that's good to know.
>> Yeah.
And that actually comes up in a really
important setting,
which is if you're doing not, say,
epsilon greedy, exploration which
corresponds to the third line here.
But instead we're doing something
like Boltzmann exploration
we could run into trouble.
So, I think that it's for this kind of
introduction to generalized MDPs and
I think that actually finishes
the section on convergence.
So you're ready for some recap?
>> Yes I love recapping.